i did get one request unfortunately i
had to cancel that booking but they were
gonna they bought me like cat ears and
they wanted me to like drink milk out of
like a little bowl and basically pretend
to be a cat
yeah that was that was odd but it's not
the oddest one i've ever had
[Music]
i've done a couple of different things i
was i worked in the hospital ages ago as
a healthcare assistant and then i was
training for my childhood accountancy i
was worked in finance and banking for
um six years actually
i had a series alongside this of like
serious monogamous relationships and
then when i ended um my sort of last
long term when i had i have found myself
single and really curious to experiment
sexually a lot more so i started going
to these sex parties in london there's
this brand called killing kittens it's
quite it's quite well known it's just
basically like a sex party event a lot
of couples swingers and single girls can
go so i went as a single girl that sort
of launched me into kind of like this
kind of sex hedonistic kind of lifestyle
a little bit and i was going to a lot of
these parties and meeting a lot of
different kind of people and then sort
of by weird turn of events over covered
i needed somewhere to live
and i sort of ended up living in that
kind of mansion and then when i moved in
there i actually was living with about
five other escorts which was really
funny
um because i sort of turned up and are
like oh what are you doing like are you
working like a working girl too and i
was like no i'm an accountant i am
became really good friends with a few of
them and one of them who's still kind of
my mentor today and she introduced me to
the job because i guess i just saw them
like really enjoying themselves and i
was really curious about it as well and
i thought you know i'll give it a go see
what it's like you know if they're
having a fun time maybe i'll have a fun
time you know
um gave it a go and then sort of fell in
love with it really
my first ever client i still remember
him it was just he was quite a good
looking guy i think he's around 30
dressed quite well smart spell clean
yeah obviously the whole time i was like
sweating like i was so nervous which was
ridiculous because i'd had so many so
much sex before and like i'd had one
night stand before everything like that
so it almost felt like why was i so
nervous they were suddenly just like
another hookup but you know it's paid
for it why i wasn't so nervous about it
but i was but it was fine i had a good
time he was a good client paid me for an
hour had we had fun had sex and then
left off half an hour so
yeah it wasn't it was great and i was
there with the money being like wow like
i can actually do this i guess
and and what does your
like profiles say is is it kind of like
a you will do this this this this and
this
yeah
yeah pretty much it's like um just says
like my rates and it says look this is
what i do this is my office i offer sex
with condom or without condom anal for
50 pound extra
um
come in mouth um like i put what i don't
like i hate facials for example i put i
don't do that and i sort of put like
anything extra kinky or taboo like
considered on requests because they tend
to be a bit more niche requests so just
depending on what they asked me for yeah
and talk us through a usual booking for
you what does that look like um it's the
usual booking like most people book for
an hour you know i won't have met them
before or anything like that because i
get a lot of new clients maybe you know
obviously i could get regulars as well
but you know they'll send a message like
oh i want to see you at this time for
this long and maybe if they have a
special request like they want me to
dress and i don't know in a school go
outfit or do a certain role play and
i'll sort of say yes no whatever and
then i'll come to the door and like i'll
let them in greet them offer them a
shower
um if they haven't already showered um
and then yeah i'll come straight into my
room i'll already be like half naked in
lingerie or um anyway and yeah we'll
just kind of just take even though it
usually flows really naturally you know
just start kissing and stuff like then
suck head or like see what they want to
do if they want to take the lead and
then end up having sex one hour you can
usually fit in two rounds so you just
will have one round have a little break
give them a massage until they're ready
to go again
and do you have any regulars yeah i do
yeah i do have quite a lot of riggers i
mean anal is quite popular because i
think i kind of fit in a niche of like a
lot of
asian girls don't really offer anal so i
get a lot of anal requests which is yeah
i guess
but not so fun when they're too big
could you explain how the different
ethnic groups are treated in your
industry um yeah i mean from there from
the ethnic like the african women i've
known who are sex workers they
i like have heard it now a lot they get
a lot less business um
and yes which is a shame i think and you
know as well even for me like again
compared to like a work caucasian lady
like i've
you know i kind of have seen how busy
she gets and i am less busy than her
definitely as well so you know people do
like race play as well i do get some
requests for that so yeah it can
definitely be fetishized in that way
what are the different role plays and
things you've done for people um some
odd ones have been like um
like you know like foot fetish kind of
people which are great fun because it's
like quite easy because i just lie back
in base and get a foot massage but there
was this one who liked
like literally licking the dirt off my
feet so he'd like message me and be like
look can you go to the gym or have you
been to the gym or have you been for a
walk outside with like no socks on or
make sure you haven't showered so i'd
feel a bit gross because obviously i
like showering but he'd love it so
whatever that's fine but schoolgirl is
quite a popular one i think it's like
the asian school girl look like if they
ask for like the black set of lingerie i
mean for example i've done a photo shoot
in this outfit so yeah some people quite
like assuming this it's just yeah i
don't know it's just a three-piece
suspender i think i got it from anne
summers and
fishnets and just down my stripper heels
i did get one request unfortunately i
had to cancel that booking but they were
gonna they bought me like cat ears and
they wanted me to like drink milk out of
like a little bowl and basically pretend
to be a cat yeah that was that was odd
but it's not the oddest one i've ever
had and i have a butt plug with like a
fairy tale on which i know some people
quite like
are you in a relationship at the moment
no but i do i date kind of like openly
and like casually a lot so i have quite
like a few lovers and i guess but no not
anything serious
and you talk to them about
your job yeah i'm completely open with
my job like everyone i know who knows me
on like a personal level knows what i do
so yeah they're absolutely aware of it
it only really becomes a problem
obviously if you get kind of feelings
and that you want like something serious
with someone like me who's in my kind of
industry but everything up until then
most people are quite chilled out yeah
does your job make it difficult having a
personal relationship of your own um
yeah immensely i mean i wouldn't
i don't know yeah i feel like it's
something i've kind of committed myself
to not bothering with while i do this
job because i actually kind of wouldn't
want to do that to someone like it's you
know i'm not going to be there for like
a lot of evenings or like i'm going to
be away other guys
apartments a lot or like
you know i don't have the kind of time
or
i'm not around in that kind of way for
something that's more serious i've
earned yeah it would be difficult you
know like for example you couldn't even
like live with your partner right
because you kind of always like i need
my own place to do my job out of and how
can you live with someone when you need
to be like taking clients into your
apartment right so you can't even do
things like that
what would you say is the most difficult
part of what you do
um difficult fact
i don't know i just love it so much i'm
not sure what's difficult about it
um i don't know sometimes like
probably physically like after a day it
can be tiring as well i think i
mentioned if i'm doing like a lot of
anal sex and they have quite like big um
because then it can be quite like yeah
physically challenging to like take it i
guess sometimes or if they just go quite
hard or sometimes you can get you know
people just being a little bit
disrespectful but it doesn't happen
often but i feel like any client facing
job you can get that anyway
have you ever had to kind of stop
halfway because
um yeah i think well this happened ages
ago i think it was because i was quite
new to the job i think it's about like
literally one month in and i had the
client which i just i don't know
something about that attitude and their
way they were having sex with me like
they were forcing me like making me gag
quite a lot and i wasn't really enjoying
it and
um it just was like yeah making me
really uncomfortable and i i sort of
freaked out a bit and then like asked
them to stop and they weren't really
they kept trying to like force me to
like take that anyway eventually i
kicked them out but
um
that yeah i think i was quite new at
that point so i think i just freaked out
i didn't know how to handle it did you
see them again that's kind of a good
thing about um the job as well is like i
think people assume that i see people
who i don't like or i'm forced to do
things i don't like i just refuse to do
things if i don't like it or just don't
see them again if i don't like them but
yeah i've definitely had irritating ones
who've made weird racist comments or
just said stuff that's kind of offensive
or been a bit disrespectful and i just
don't see them again do you ever feel
judged by people because of your work
um
and sometimes a little bit i think the
way i am is because i'm so open about it
i'm so willing to explain it and i guess
probably it helps as well i've done like
other things like i've had education or
whatever like people
um
won't really judge me because it's not
like this isn't like the whole of my
life i've done over things but i
definitely do feel like if um
maybe if it was just a whole of my life
or maybe if i didn't have as much
education it's very very easy to quickly
judge and yeah some people definitely
feel uncomfortable talking about it or
just find my life
like they find a fact that i love it and
have chosen this life like really really
bizarre and just incomprehensible but
why do you think you're
so successful at it and others might not
be
um i don't know i think i think you've
got to love it like because i met a few
escorts who didn't really love the job
and i always questioned why or like how
anyone would enjoy see them if you if
you it's clearly someone who's not
enjoying doing it um so i think a
natural hopefully love for sex should
kind of come with a territory really and
yeah just hopefully yeah good with
people that probably helps but and where
do you see yourself kind of in the
future of your work
um well i'm definitely going to be
continuing this for as long as i enjoy
it which i mean it could be a few years
it could be longer than that um but ever
since being self-employed i don't think
i'd go back to being employed again so i
think eventually i'll kind of use the
kind of money i've saved to just have my
own business and something instead and
one of the things you love about what
you do
um i really love it when obviously i
like just just me just being a teenage
girl right when i get really nice hot
clients that make me orgasm really
really well i love that or like when
when they just give me a great time i
mean who doesn't love that when they
give yeah you know basically you know
some days like maybe if i have a great
day this would be a great day for me
it's like if i get like three or four
orgasms in a day from my clients i'm
like yes i feel amazing
[Music]
it's
a lot firmer than a wooden cane that
people traditionally use um
and it's
yeah leaves some very nice wells which i
love making marks on men's bottoms